bring bill off the bench in my opinion
bring him off the bench yeah
B cuz you can't it's only one ball at
you're not going to have have three guys
out there Taylor Hendrick on the wrong
end of a couple of highlights give me
something bbo look at that come on come
on Kenny come on Kenny is you giving a
guy prop shooting over a chair that's
all right same thing your boy W
do boy you better quit disrespect the
Victor disrespect I'm saying B was the
first yeah Bobo good as wom Yama y i do
he exploded for six tonight on five
shooting
129 watch this the sun's got a better
record cuz they got
car andad that's the point I'll be
trying to make we'll be talking about
the all
stuff because the team got a better
record we said I reward team not
individuality Charles barin exactly what
you said right said B say that to me Ken
so wait wait I have to agree with you
now he said record is everything so B
got a better record if whim Yama was on
the signs with Kevin Durant Booker and
KD they probably had the same record
they might
not they might not ever lose a game they
might not ever lose a game might lose a
game you're the I do like er said ER
said boy exploded
for